very very definite attitudes toward
every phase of alcohol
toward alcoholics
toward alcoholism
even toward drinking toward drunkenness
in fact toward alcoholics
our attitudes come from our parents
from our religious background our
cultural background but above all else
from our contact with some alcoholic
every one of you knows an alcoholic
in fact at least five of you live with
one actively drinking
in fact that there are a minimum of
three
active alcoholics here face it that's
just a statistic
so many of us will die from cancer so
many of us will die from other things so
many of us will die in accidents so many
of us will die of alcoholism
a fact it is the number one health
problem in the united states
hugh downes on the today show was the
only other man besides myself who has
ever had the nerve publicly to say that
he firmly believes as do i that there
are a minimum of 18 million alcoholics
every one of whom affects it seriously
affects a minimum
of six other people good evening's
industry calls it the billion dollar
hangover
but let's let's examine some of the
background sources of our attitudes
we are all right here products of the
so-called temperance movement that was
born in the united states about a
century ago
they went very quickly from temperance
to abstinence
because you see they went from a
condemnation of alcoholism and
alcoholics to the next very logical step
condemnation of drinking
and then those who drink
and then
a kind of insanity
intelligent people passed a moralistic
judgment on an inanimate object alcohol
is evil
and some of us were raised with that
notion
this is very intimately wrapped up in
our religious background orthodox jews
hardly know what you're talking about
when you mention alcoholism
they are raised
one with proper attitudes
and two they do not tolerate drunkenness
you get drunk once as a jew and you're
accused of being drunk like a gentile
race let's take the jews they are raised
almost from birth and have been for
centuries on wine
the american indian had no past cultural
usage of alcohol he was a sitting duck
for alcoholism we're all here old enough
to remember the saturday afternoon bean
movies the chiefs called it fire water
the west was not one with the winchester
rifles one with barrels of whiskey it
wasn't bill cody and batmasterson and
wyatt earp and uh while bill had got
conquered the west
it was jim beam and iw harper and old
granddad few of those fellas
uh
let's take this aspect of it
islam forbids the use of alcohol
american mormonism forbids the use of
alcohol
of arabians who drink one out of three
becomes an alcoholic and of mormons one
out of two
because those who drink drink with guilt
the attitudes in this country go ahead
go to a football or baseball game and
watch the reactions to a drunk there is
no single reaction some people laugh
nervously others say isn't that funny
etc etc
dean martin says whiskey and everybody
falls apart laughing
the jew just sits astonished at such a
thing you know would you laugh when
automobile is mentioned
but again above all else
our attitudes are formed basically by
our contact
with some alcoholic
there's a nurse in baltimore who has
done about 12 years of work in emergency
rooms her definition which she gave at a
seminar about two years ago what's an
alcoholic
hers was this an alcoholic is my uncle
no parents she was raised by an aunt and
uncle the uncle was an alcoholic he was
also the world's worst
wife beater child beater and so on
significant was this that's what she saw
every time a sick alcoholic was wheeled
in the emergency room that's where she
treated him
alcoholism is the oldest disease known
to mankind
it is the most complex and the most
devastating it affects every single
facet of the human person body mind
emotions and soul
and it's the illness about which we know
the least
face it ladies and gentlemen what you
know is what you see
and what you see is alcoholic behavior
and face it it's
obnoxious what we don't see is what we
don't see of an iceberg
what's hidden
most of us are enamored of causes
now with this in mind and we waste
billions on psychiatric treatment which
is given and received at the wrong time
i'll discuss that a little later
but what happens is this our reasoning
says if he knows why he drinks the
problem will disappear now let me ask
you this any of you ever go to a dentist
doctor this tooth is killing tell me why
it hurts
you don't get the drill get the drill
make it stop hurting
you may indeed know the the molecular
structure of all the goop that goes into
your mouth and the composition of enamel
and pulp and dentin and everything else
and the interaction of the two so what
that does not make it stop hurting and
knowing why he drinks doesn't make an
alcoholic stop drinking
after he has stopped properly knowing
why he drinks may keep him sober but it
has little or nothing to do with getting
him that way but again i'm getting ahead
of myself
um of
the 18 million alcoholics in this
country there are about a half million
sober ones
the fact
one out of 36 gets well the other 35
died
just died
so what we're here for this morning is
to find out a little bit about alcohol
and then about alcoholism
and as was indicated the information is
not i can boast of it because it is not
my own it came from a little doctor who
was himself a recovered alcoholic
he lost everything because of his
drinking beginning with his license to
practice medicine from there he went
down
and he wound up in the gutter on
michigan avenue in detroit but he got
well and he went back to the top of his
profession with this difference
he dedicated the remaining years of his
medical life to the treatment of
alcoholic patients and he treated over
six thousand of them now this little man
knew what he was talking about
and even though the problem is complex
the answers are very simple indeed
and i hope that just as i was you will
be impressed by the genius of this man's
simplicity
i think that in this realm our brains
get in our way
i have noticed this personally in aaa i
have met many people too smart to get
sober i've never met one too stupid to
never
the trouble with a human animal is his
brains get in his way often
anyway
doc green used to begin at the beginning
the things we drink and why
it is important to know
the first thing that crosses human lips
is water and it is drunk to fulfill a
need
slake's thirst
is drunk for the simplest of reasons the
second thing is milk
and it too is drunk to fulfill a need
the maintenance of health
you remember from your high school
biology classes
the scientists classifies us as milk
drinkers that's what we're called in
textbooks we are mammals
from the latin word mama breast the
source of milk these two
beverages since necessary are quite
natural but we drink other things for
other reasons
we're introduced usually when we are
young
because of a preference for sweetness in
the taste buds at a very young with
something sweet
soft drink hot chocolate cocoa anything
and the reason again is a simple one
it's different from these two but it is
still simple did you ever notice
that most professions or disciplines
have their own jargon and vocabulary
with which they try to dazzle the rest
of the world with their intellectual
footwork
uh you know what the scientist says this
is drunk for oral gratification
now that's a seven cent phrase it means
it tastes good
and that's exactly why it is drunk it
pleases a desire
it simply tastes good
then we come to the first beverage it
contains a drug coffee and the drinking
of coffee is
learned you know why we have to learn to
drink it it's not necessary it doesn't
taste good
well why in the world do we learn to
drink such a thing
well the first reason is the simplest of
all curiosity
the big people drink it and don't give
us any
and when we get old enough to ask we're
told we can't have it when we ask why
they say it's not good for you so we
want some
so somebody'll take a little coffee cut
it with milk or cream add a little sugar
to make it somewhat pleasing to taste
take a sip you're doing just a big
people do
that's your first step out of infancy is
drinking a big people beverage
custom dictates its use
just as tea is drunk in other countries
coffee is drunk here
in fact the coffee break is so customary
that i think it's written into some
labor contracts
and then there is this social aspect
that is hardly definable this business
of conviviality by the way i hope you
noticed i was talking while i was
writing that word many people think that
great achievements consist in degrees
after your name or or promotions and so
on i consider that a major achievement
in my life
it took me three years to learn to do
that to keep anyway then we come to
alcohol
the drinking of which is also learned
but to get to this conviviality thing i
i skipped it
it's the coffee break you are not
thirsty a sip of water takes care of
that but everybody else is sitting
around conversing and exchanging ideas
and so you have a cup of coffee too
there is a social aspect to the drinking
of coffee at certain times
alcohol is not necessary and doesn't
taste good we acquire a taste for it
just as we acquire taste for raw oysters
or olives or whatever
some people drink until they die never
having acquired a taste for
what are the reasons that are given for
drinking alcohol there are external and
internal pressures
both of which are strong the first is
curiosity again the big people drink it
and don't give us any we're told it's
not good for us and so on and so forth
somewhere along the line somebody's
going to take a little whiskey cut it
with water or ice had a little sugar to
sweeten it a little garbage to color
take a sip we're doing just what the big
people do
now ladies and gentlemen i
presume that most of us are fairly
intelligent
we educate our kids to think this way we
do it with our sophisticated 20th
century law when you're 21 you can drink
that's why half of you here and perhaps
most of your kids will sneak out of a
prom to take a drink of beer or whiskey
they never dream of doing this with a
coke we've educated them to think that
way it's the big people drink is the big
shot thing to do and that contributes to
attitude
custom dictates its use before men knew
how to write that's the way they made
contracts your drink was binding just as
was a handshake
just as is a signature um
his customary drink at births
and deaths
and weddings we toast the bride and
champagne
wakes
holidays celebrations graduations holy
days feast days fast days sundays
mondays tuesdays wednesdays you go right
down the line it's customary to drink
and conviviality
important vastly important
and it's far more conducive to
conviviality than all the coffee grown
take a room full of let's say 75 people
and you don't know each other too well
everybody's a little stiff
pardon the expression
and formal
circulate a couple of gallons of
martinis and stick your head in the same
room about an hour or so later
everybody is about as convivial as they
can be and they're quite at ease with
each other there's a biochemical reason
why that is so
and we'll see it in a minute
alcohol is drunk for escape now forget
all the background ins and outs of
psychiatric reasoning i'm talking about
normal people with normal problems you
want to get away from them take three
and a half four martinis the problems
are still there but they don't bother
you now
and there's a biochemical reason why
that is so
and for those who can take it as
marvelous here in the united states
about one out of eight will become
alcoholic the other seven can drink
until their death enjoying it in fact
scripture refers to wine as the gift of
god that gladdens the hearts of men
tensions frustrations anxieties jobs
husbands lives take three drinks and
just settle back for a couple hours it's
wonderful
pain is a reason given in fact uh beer
and wine have been beverages from the
beginning distillation what produces
whiskey and gin and the the so-called
hard stuff wasn't discovered until
fairly recently in the history of man
and when it came into being was used as
medication only
but now it's a beverage and i strongly
suspect people who use pain as their
reason for drinking say would you get
drunk last night for when you get an
answer like receding gums you know
there's trouble
there's trouble there's a fellow naa
over in baltimore it's over 17 years now
when he was drinking and couldn't make
it into work he'd call in say i got to
go to the dentist get a tooth out
he was sober about a year and he and his
boss were talking about his drinking
and the boys opened his desk drawer and
pulled out a sheet of paper he said ross
you know when you were drinking he said
you had 75 teeth extracted
here's what i mean by dr green's
simplicity
euphoria is why the human animal drinks
alcohol that's a 32 cent greek word that
means a sense of well-being this is why
you spend two dollars for a cocktail you
could buy a case of orange for the same
price
but that little old glass with two
ounces of booze and it does what all the
orange in the world can't do makes you
feel good
here's where he used to argue by the
hour by the week by the month and by the
year
with his medical colleagues
the answer is just too simple to be true
i demand
complexity
isn't true at all now why do you want to
feel good now you can fill psychiatric
libraries but that's why the human
animal drinks alcohol now fascinatingly
enough the chemistry of alcohol
don't let this scare you
alcohol is a chemical
composed of carbon oxygen and hydrogen i
know no chemistry i flunked it in
college
i know that h2o is water and k9p comes
from the south end of a dog and that
ends my
knowledge of formula
alcohol is not a food and has no food
properties there are no minerals no
vitamins no proteins in fact the stomach
can't digest it
the stomach digests what it's in
beer for example is about five six
percent alcohol the rest of his food
stuff but the alcohol itself is not
digested it's oxidized by the liver
but anyway basically it's a solvent and
one of the best in the world
it'll remove stains from tables
tables
stomachs
uh bankrolls
marriages just friendships high it's the
best
it's the arose leaked upon the stimulant
because of the wacky things people do
when they drink it
i would guess that at least a fistful of
you think alcohol stimulates because
of what people do when they get a couple
but it isn't
it's an antiseptic the nurse purifies
arms or legs or
wherever she wants to stick needles
before she sticks the needle in
for centuries it was the only anesthetic
that mankind had
it's a poor one and we'll see why
when wine was offered to christ on the
cross it was meant as an act of simple
human kindness cheap wine was standard
equipment
in the execution kits of the of the
romans who killed people by crucifixion
basically in its drinkable form
alcohol is a sedative drug
and alcoholism is addiction to it now
that's the whole morning in a sentence
alcohol is a sedative drug
and alcoholism is addiction to it
i maintain firmly and strongly we know
nothing of addiction
nothing the only thing we can do is
describe it
and so
and treat it
but what it is god knows
and usually he won't tell
all addiction is characterized by
compulsive use of the addictive
substance and that's why the drinker
that you know drinks the way he does
he doesn't will it
he drinks that way against his will
would that he could handle it that's his
problem
he tries to handle it he can't
now addiction is progressive and once
contracted it progresses until death
even though you can stop or arrest the
addiction the addiction is still there
and it worsens when it has gone back to
but we'll see about that in a minute
here i think is dr green's genius he
does the obvious
he shows that alcohol is a sedative drug
by comparing its action with that of an
accepted anesthetic drug ether
which like all sedatives interferes
with the oxygen supply to the brain and
puts it to sleep
the brain as you know is an organ
composed of parts that control functions
i realize this is simplistic for any of
you who may be connected with medicine
but this is the way it was presented to
us it's the way we understood it it's
the way i pass it on to you
the outermost part of the brain houses
reason the intellect
beneath that
the emotions the imagination the memory
deeper still is that part controlling
your motor activity the movement of
parts your arms and legs
there are the semi-voluntary functions
like the blinking of your eyes at times
you have control over it at times a gust
of wind you blink involuntarily there
are purely involuntary functions
the action of your stomach and your
intestines
and then from the latin word vita life
there are those functions essential to
life which we call vital
your heartbeat your breathing now the
brain goes to sleep from outside in it
can be done almost instantaneously but
step by step that's the way it goes out
everybody here also has some notion
and correct i'm sure of adulthood or
maturity
an adult is somebody with a sense of
responsibility
or one who tries to fulfill a sense of
responsibility
an adult is someone sensitive to the
sensitivities of other people
cardinal newman's classic definition of
a gentleman one who does not consciously
cause pain
dr green's definition one who functions
this away
according to the formula i over e his
intellect controls his emotions
going along with the entire school of
scholasticism founded by aquinas man is
a rational animal
now let's see what happens to that
formula
when the brain that controls it is
interfered with
by adding a drug to it
first of all
there's a dryness in the throat it's
highly absorbent of moisture dries out
those mucous membranes and you get this
vague sense of suffocation you want to
rip the mask off and gulp fresh air but
before you can do that you feel good
we
get the picture
you have just left your room
clad in what is euphemistically called a
hospital gown
uh i think they're obscene personally
then they put you on a hard metal cart
and guess how you get to the operating
room
no one
no one has ever explained to me
from hospital designer administrator
doctor or nurse
why in the most modern hospital where
they perform surgery all day every day
there's no such thing as an elevator for
surgical patients you go down on the
public elevator there are always about
three or four clowns doing one of these
on you as you go down then they wheel
you into the operating room where there
are six ghouls
and they're standing there in cap mask
and gown and guess what color you know
some psychologists have earned their
doctorates writing theses
on color and how it affects morale and
so on so forth
after ninety two thousand launderings
these hospital gowns now are vomit green
and you're there with an empty belly at
8 10.
and then the fella who used to be your
friend the night before walks in this
way
they're going to stick a knife in his
hand he's going to stick it in your
belly in about 30 seconds and you
couldn't care less
if the nurse were to bend over say you
know we're gonna have to remove that
whole arm you say take them both i've
got legs
you would it doesn't bother you and the
reason is the simplest in the world the
first part of the brain that is hit is
what would make you feel bad reason
it's now gone
in fact they give you a needle before
you leave the room you're half flaky by
the time you get down there
so it's i over e except after d add a
drug and watch what you get this is
highly important
control
over the emotions is now gone
[Music]
what happens is they come out
you have a reversal of the formula
and immediately enter an excitement
stage
and with your motor activity affected
since you could harm yourself that's why
that she trapped rather tightly around
you and that's why the medical personnel
are now standing close to you
watch this
the emotions have come out this is why
you say wacky things
this is also why medical ethics forbids
them to bear outside that room what you
bear inside it
and the reason is the simplest in the
world
when the emotions come out they do not
come out let's say normal if there is
such a thing
they come out drug affected because
that's the next part of the brain hit
they come out drug affected
now let me ask you a question that might
sound silly and stupid
but it's very valid
how many of you listening to a patient
babble
on a table in an operating room
would say good heavens he needs a
psychiatrist
what would you think of psychiatrists
who go wandering from operating room to
operating room trying to apply
psychiatric care he said they need help
themselves and you'd be right
but just bear that in mind for a minute
you may or may not get sick that's
neither here nor there
since these two things are dangerous
they try to slam you through them as
quickly as they can
there is however a nurse there with a
basin to catch anything you have to
offer
normally there won't be they keep that
entire intestinal tract empty
uh beginning the night before
by use of the most sophisticated medical
technique known to god and man
uh it's called the enema is what it's
called and could
personally i think it's inhumane and
barbaric but i don't know of any other
way
i had six in in three days one time i
was in for a complete checkup
and uh
by the fourth when that fellow walked in
with the fourth animal i saluted him
my downstairs i called him the rear
admiral the fourth floor
that's
that to me is is uh
as irritating as the surgery itself
really
but when the semi-voluntary functions go
you are in pre-anesthesia simple
unconsciousness you cannot yet be cut
when the involuntary functions go you
are in anesthesia
and can undergo surgery
the next step is obvious the only thing
left is your heart beating your
breathing and i have heard
every surgeon who has ever been to one
of these meetings has always come up
afterwards he says i wish the heavens
people would realize
that despite the nature of the surgery
if you undergo any surgery by general
anesthesia in which your brain is
sedated down to here there's no such
thing as minor surgery you're as close
to death as you will ever be
this is why to keep a person between
anesthesia and death because death
results when the vital functions go
is highly dangerous indeed most
anesthesiologists are md's who do
nothing but this
coming out of it you go through the same
process in reverse from anesthesia to
pre-anesthesia you'll be sick and you
undergo an excitement stage
ether is terribly conducive to nausea
this is why they use anything else they
can
and part of the sickness particularly
after abdominal surgery is this
phenomenon called gas
those of you who have experienced it
know what i mean and if you haven't
experienced it you can only imagine
in the middle of the first day after
surgery you are afraid you might die and
in the middle of the second when you're
afraid you might not
and i'm dead serious about that too you
do not care if the next minute of your
life shows up or not hey you know what
happens
uh a surgeon friend of mine explained he
says you come to but they don't for
about three days this is why they try to
get you ambulatory and while they try to
get you to eat and so on as soon after
surgery is possible to activate those
things what causes the pain is the
distention of the intestines caused by
gas you can cut an intestine without
feeling it hardly
but just distend it ever so slightly
which is what a cramp is
and and the pain is almost unbearable
now watch standard medical procedure
you go to recovery room
until you're conscious then back to your
own room and as soon as this team of
usually about four or five pros gets you
back into bed in almost a split second
the first procedure performed as a
massive dose of morphine
is to prevent hurting yourself in the
excitement stage and also and quite
obviously to alleviate the pain now
there will not be any euphoria for
obvious reasons now watch
i have never
ceased to be impressed by this
cross out ether substitute alcohol
it does exactly the same thing
ladies and gentlemen please remember
this as such this has nothing to do with
alcoholism this has to do with alcohol
what it does when you drink it
uh a biochemist showed me this about a
month ago
to get ether what you do is you take
two alcohol molecules
here's one
now watch h
o
c two h five
and you remove the water
h2o
that's ether
practically speaking one is the other
without the water in it
and by the way this is just a personal
thing for those of you who are parents
you do not you cannot teach your
children how to drink
and if they are teenagers
your capacity to teach them is long gone
anyway
what you have to give your children
number one is a sense of values
and proper attitudes
and then you hope to god that when they
hit their teen years when they will
choose that they choose responsibly
and that's what you have to give your
children
attitudes and a sense of values
that's it
well how do i teach my children to drink
you don't when i'm asked that question i
say probably the same way you teach them
to use goofballs
this is a drug
now it comes in beverage form please
remember that god gave it to us in that
form it is simply what it is you don't
use this information to scare kids with
the fear tactic it will not work
they know
that most people who drink do not become
alcoholics they'll turn you off like
that anyway
the first thing we feel with alcohol is
the first paradox about its nature it's
a liquid that dries out your throat now
for those of us who know it all do you
ever say here wet your whistle well it
doesn't it dries your whistle the chaser
wet your whistle that's why we invented
it that's why we invented a mixed drink
to do away with the unpleasant burning
sensation caused by the dryness and the
irritation
and also to make it somewhat palatable
now if you don't of course beer and wine
have a kind of a minor percentage of
alcohol it's it's the spirits you know
that that hurt
now if you've never experienced that try
it with a straight shot when you go home
or if you don't care to go to a football
game and watch the reaction there's some
clown up in the stands with a half pint
and he takes a big smash and you get
oh that was good
and they use the tears are streaming
down his cheeks and so on
well that's what happens
it dries out the mucous membranes of the
throat because it's highly absorbent of
moisture and it causes this irritation
here however
after a while you'll feel good then you
don't mind the burning
now why do you feel going to drink
alcohol
what is not oxidized by the liver gets
in the bloodstream
and the blood ultimately brings it to
the brain where it begins to sedate it
how do we know simple observation dr
green is not teaching anything here he's
pointing out to you what you already
know let me ask you this do you know
when you're in a room full of people
drinking
it's obvious isn't it somebody very
drunk staggers
and by the way alcohol is noticeable i
just can't buy this stuff people say you
know i know a guy drinks 18 gallons a
day and you'd never know it
well you'd probably never know it
because you've never seen him sober
he said you ever hear that story and i'm
sure the navy men here are familiar with
it the fella that the first mate or
whatever who keeps the log
the captain was drunk today the captain
was drunk today this went off for years
the captain discovered it he says don't
put that in there so the fella didn't
so i think it was eight years later
there was an entry one day i think it
was july 13th the captain was sober
today yeah
you feel good when you drink
because alcohol knocks out of the
picture what would make you feel bad
this is why it's a marvelous escape from
your problems
this is why
and people feel good you can see it
you can see it and here is where you see
it you ever see a drunk try light of
cigarettes a major production
to watch him zero in on the end of that
thing
but before he gets drunk
in canada one of the finest films on
alcohol is a thing called 0.08 about
blood alcohol level
they use professional racing drivers
they gave them two shots
that's it put them behind wheels of cars
then they had to go through one of these
obstacle courses these are professionals
professionals and one man was actually
cussing himself because he's not in
pylons over
he felt he was functioning well
but he wasn't
and this has to do not with alcoholism
this has to do with you who drink
you do not function better with a couple
of drinks
because you feel you function better
doesn't mean you do
well i drive better after a drink or two
no you don't you drive more relaxed you
do not drive better
there's that split second difference
getting your foot from the accelerator
to the brake
there's that weaving of the hand getting
the key in the ignition
where we notice it you can see it in
people that's slowness of the blinking
of the eyelids and then you with the
motor activity affected the tongue gets
a little bit thick just ever ever so
slightly
now we smiled ever as the way it hits
people who drink it this is the way
here's a fella he comes home from work
now he's not really a drinker but
they're celebrating something he's with
some of the fellas he has about nine
well of course he walks in an hour and
three quarters late the dinner is burned
she's furious she says you've been
drinking he stands there swaying this is
all uh
um i i mean just just how can you stand
stand there your face hanging out that
way and
accuse me of drinking
he thinks he's functioning perfectly
so do you when you drink
so do you when you drink
now watch
we see funny behavior
in drinkers
because the emotions are now up here
all right
and
previously intelligent people are now
saying real nutty things and repeating
themselves now if you want to know what
i mean go to your next cocktail party
and don't drink
after about three quarters of an hour
you either want to throw up go home or
get drunk yourself just to take it
significant is this please remember
after a couple of drinks you know we
think we've discovered truth serum it's
been around for centuries called booze
and the latins eight thousand years
before christ had an expression in vino
veritas in wine there is truth you won't
know what somebody drinks again for
nobody thanksgiving four five drinks
uh
in other words
fear is out of the way the inhibitions
are gone but you're not yet down here
and so you talk freely however after a
few more drinks
now watch please
when the emotions come out they come out
drug
affected they come out drug affected we
are looking at goofy emotional behavior
now let me ask the same question that we
left out before
how many of you have ever looked at a
problem drinker and said he needs a
psychiatrist
and how many people in high places have
spent fortunes
on valuable personnel sending them to
psychiatrists
who are very wise by
well no that's neither here or there but
just let me ask you what do you think of
a psychiatrist who would never dream of
trying to treat somebody on the
influence of ether but tries to drink
actively practicing alcoholics
this is important i'm not saying that
psych psychiatric therapy isn't
necessary what i'm saying is this that
first
sobriety he does not need psychiatry now
he needs to get sober to find out if he
needs a psychiatrist
how would you know whether a patient on
an operating table needs psychiatry for
his personal emotional and mental
problems you say for god's sake get the
ether out of him and examine him
it's the same way with the alcoholic get
the drug out good lord he's been bathing
his brain in a drug for 15 18 years
he needs sobriety
to find out
to find out if he needs psychiatric care
for his emotional problems dr green has
said this
i have seen borderline psychosis clear
up
with
sobriety it is not whether or not he
needs it some alcoholics do in fact dr
green and everyone who has ever done a
study on it has found out
that the percentage of alcoholics who do
need psychiatric attention is exactly
the same as a percentage of the
non-alcoholic population about 7-10
percent of all people need care
so
the conclusion
in the initial stages of recovery
psychiatry is contraindicated get him
sober first
dr green used to say of those who do
need care he put it
semi-crudely
but truly
if you were nuts before you started to
drink you'll be a little flakier after
you quit and you will need subsequent
care all right
with the emotions on top
affected by the drug alcohol this is
what we see whatever you are basically
here exaggerated
there's the joko's type
the life of the party very shy
can't get through his own name making an
introduction give him five drinks he's
on the piano leading the songs there's
the bellicose type the little teeny
fella with the julius caesar complex
very quiet very subdued very shy very
diffident
give him eight or nine bangs of this
liquid moral courage and he's going to
challenge the entire bar as we say in
aaa you can spot them they're usually
the new men with the new teeth
then there's the lacrimos or crying
drunk you ever met one
if you'd like to put on a roman collar
and get on a train
you get in the last seat way back as far
as you can get
and after train pulls out the station
about three minutes later some clown
steps in from the club car
and he spots that one square inch of
white many a drunk who is very drunk
can't quite focus they tell one of a
drunk going down the street and two nuns
walking up they didn't know what to do
because he was staggering but when they
got near him they separated one around
him and he stopped saying how did she do
that
well courtney you can't he can't quite
focus but he
anyway
you may or may not get sick as you drink
that's neither here nor there you do not
have to get sick but if you drink enough
you will pass out
three paradoxes about alcohol
it's a liquid that dries out your throat
it is a sedative that seems to stimulate
and it's an anesthetic it can't
anesthetize precisely because it's a
liquid it must be drunk and when you
drink down to unconsciousness you can't
pick up the glass to get you down to
here how then does alcoholism kill
through cirrhosis through malnutrition
and all that they give birth to
and also
oddly enough a doctor told me this about
two weeks ago he said many an alcoholic
will choke to death on his own vomit
he'd be lying on his back and just
regurgitate a little bit of his supper
and choke to death on it
and secondly or lastly by accidents
alcohol really kills
through accidents
coming out of it the drinker goes
through the same process in reverse
pre-anesthesia nauseated he'll undergo
an excitement stage but will not
experience euphoria
very briefly before we come to the end
of this segment let's look at two people
who go through this process
charlie and his aunt mabel show up for a
new year's eve party now charlie's the
alcoholic watch
he burns his throat feels good for a
while he's the life of the party changes
into filthy mcnasty somebody bangs him
in the mouth he cries in his beard and
passes out at 11 30. this is significant
ladies and gentlemen he did not intend
to be unconscious at midnight he
intended to see the new year in but he's
out
what do you do with a drunk this is very
quick and it's very practical you put
him in the car his
a very practical reason for this most
alcoholics do not eat because they
cannot but it is a new year's eve party
and there's the traditional pickled
herring he's nibbling all this stuff
there are raw oysters deviled eggs 92
000 cheese dips
nuts and pretzels and it's all sloshing
around with the vo here now about 3 30
out in the car the cold is going to wake
him up he will then sit up
wake up and throw up you make sure it's
on his upholstery never put a drunk in
your car and i'm i'm serious about it
the second thing is he undergoes the
excitement stage and at about quarter to
four everybody's ready to go home and
here's charles at the door i want a
drink now you've heard that
and guess what the wife always says
charles you've had enough
here's where two people say to each
other what two animals wouldn't
dr green's second piece of advice is the
most normal natural and intelligent in
the world he says what they do in the
hospital
knock him out with more pieces for him
say give him the drink make sure it's
that big
for two reasons and they're very solid
number one he'll get it
and number two he's got keys of the car
in his hand he's gonna drive
millions literally millions are now
being spent trying to reduce
alcohol-related highway crashes
over 50 percent of the carnage is caused
by alcoholics and over 50 percent of
pedestrians killed are alcoholics
all right now charlie's out of the way
let's look at his aunt mabel there's one
in every family ladies and gentlemen
she's strong-willed she can't understand
his addiction because she doesn't have
it
and most non-alcoholics can't
just they can't it's like me and
gambling i do not understand gambling i
can grasp it up here but down in here it
means nothing i just can't i don't
understand it
there are five addictions you know
narcotics alcohol food
and then the two purely psychological
ones gambling and work do you ever go
into a ladies house and champion the
ashtray 17 times
seriously
and you don't smoke
but mabel watch mabel mabel is
strong-willed she's got all the
questions charles where's your
self-respect he's been looking for it
for years
why don't you drink like other people
this is at the heart of the matter he
tries and can't
she's the type who wakes up in the
morning looks at her hair in the mirror
and says part and it does
it does
now watch her she doesn't drink they
sneak a screwdriver
into her well this glass of orange juice
mabel she drinks half of it you look at
her 20 minutes later she's over there
with a stupid grin on her and she
doesn't know what it is three hairs are
out of place in her footstopping time
the music and in the middle of the
second drink she passes out
both of them drank down by the way
most people who drink
drink down to here
for euphoria they get it and that's the
way they drink till they die with
perhaps an occasional drunk thrown in
it's no more problem to them the man the
moon now here are two people who drank
down to here
charlie's the alcoholic now what is an
alcoholic and we'll go into the symptoms
now so if you want to take a break now
while we can do it okay
everybody here also has some definition
of alcoholism in mind everybody does
and usually
as with addiction our definition of
alcoholism will be descriptive
it'll be based on your past knowledge
most of them i think would be true and
accurate but dr chaffetz found out from
having done a study up at massachusetts
general hospital trying to find why so
few alcoholics were being diagnosed in
emergency
discovered that one of the three major
reasons was this
where the patient's drinking pattern
paralleled out of the examining doctor
he was not an alcoholic
and i'll bet you cash
that those of you who are having trouble
with your drinking
will give a descriptive definition that
will not include you
if you're a weekend drinker isn't it
obvious that an alcoholic somebody
drinks every day
if you get drunk occasionally isn't it
obvious an alcoholic is somebody that's
drunk all the time if you drink daily
isn't it true that an alcoholic somebody
drinks in the morning and you don't etc
etc
an alcoholic is someone who's drinking
causes serious life problems it's that
simple
it is just that simple and again i think
that the validity of any statement can
be seen in the stupidity of its opposite
let me ask you this seemingly crazy
question do any of you know or have you
ever heard of
a person man woman or child who has ever
wrecked an automobile totaled it and
nearly killed himself as a result of
eating string beans
have you ever heard that
we've all known people have nearly
killed themselves because they were
drunk now you can wreck a car for many
reasons but if alcohol is the reason
alcohol is a problem
face it i can't prove this it's a
self-evident truth to prove you step
behind and show something up a clearer
light i can't prove this what makes
problems is one
i can't prove that you buy it or you
don't
let me again describe there's a young
fellow in jessup's cut
he is serving twenty to life he has no
left arm
started to go to aaa meetings because
his cellmate did that's all one
something to do
he had no more notion of alcohol
alcoholism man the moon but while there
he heard what makes trouble is trouble
and if your alcohol causes trouble
it's a problem with you
this boy got drunk three times in his
life
the first time he lost his arm the
second time he lost his family and the
third time he committed a crime that
lost him his freedom he concluded
correctly he's an alcoholic but how many
of you have ever looked at someone in
the family
someone you work for
someone who works for you and said this
totally insane thing
well yeah he drinks but he's not that
bad yet
now he's not what bad yet
he's not what bad yet
he weightly is dead and perhaps conclude
he had a little trouble with his
drinking
this is the insanity of behind
misinformation in this field there is no
field on earth in which the half truth
results in more tragedy than this one
if you honest to heavens believe that
alcoholism is a disease then it's
diagnosable and treatable
some symptoms of alcoholism and if you
know a few of these you can write the
rest of the story on any alcoholic that
you know
it's just a question of details
hold onto your chairs
all alcoholics drink too much
you say well good heavens i know that
this characterizes all alcoholics and
excessive drinking pattern now let me
ask you this how much is too much
see it doesn't have to do with any
constant amount
it's purely relative too much is however
much is too much for you that's too much
and too much is what makes problems let
me show you we call alcoholism a disease
of mind here's the way he functions
and please bear this in mind all the way
through
he can get the troops out of vietnam in
three weeks asking why doesn't the
president call me
he can't get out of bed
but he's going to get troops out of
vietnam
he can solve world problems can't handle
his own i know it's kiters in detroit
used to treat alcoholics and he was good
but in between patients he'd reach into
the drawer and boom it's the only way to
get through today
the problems
blackout
just as all people addicts and
non-addicts will be affected by ether
all people are going to be affected by
alcohol now alcoholics and
non-alcoholics can experience blackouts
but tell a non-alcoholic fairly normal
person who can't remember last night but
who has a dent in his right front fender
that he may have hit somebody he'll
never drink and drive again the
alcoholic drinks and drives all the time
a blackout by the way by the way is
present inability to remember something
done recently under the influence you
remember graduating from grammar school
900 years ago i can't remember last
night
i know a woman over in baltimore married
to a man who was up for promotion to
general
at 3 a.m during the christmas holidays
her daughter home from college found her
passed out in a bedroom uh bathroom
floor it embarrassed her for about 30
seconds
this lady blacks out every time she
drinks beginning at 4 pm every afternoon
of her life she has no recollection at
all of every evening
that she drinks and it's daily
this no more faces her into man the moon
she's sick
this is way down here
gulping and sneaking drinks
if a man were to see his wife sneak into
the bathroom lift the lid off the toilet
tank pull out a bottle of milk and drink
three shots he'd have her committed in
about five minutes
now he drinks alcohol this way that's
why he drinks alcohol
and it never dawns on him is this
different from normal people
loss of control
in whatever degree why he was drunk at
his daughter's graduation of course he
was
he said he was only going to drink three
he drank 23.
he is more baffled than you
and so when you ask him why he comes up
with alibis
he has an alibi system
you know what an alibi is it's an
unreasonable reason for doing something
would you get drunk last monday night
for says it rained you say how about
twos he says it didn't
whereas the people i work with it's my
wife's big mouth it's the dog's birthday
my team won or my team lost whatever
now we laugh at the alcoholics alibis
now listen to the professional man's
well he's drunk because he has an
inferiority complex
he's drunk because
he's afraid of authority
he's drunk because he was born in the
slums
he's drunk uh
because his mommy abandoned him when he
was three
he's no such a thing drunk for those
reasons that's the professional man's
alibi system i don't mean to ridicule it
don't mistake me
we'll try to clear this up a little bit
later
but his reasons for the alcoholics
drinking are somewhat valid because they
did play a part in the alcoholics
contracting the disease that's not why
he's drunk today anyway
the eye opener
the need of a drink after a period of
deprivation please notice it's not
called the morning drink because many an
alcoholic has read somewhere if you
drink in the morning you're in so you
know what he does he shakes the pieces
till noon
his own disease depends on a wristwatch
we call it the eye opener the need of a
drink after a period of being deprived
of it sleep so normally the eye openers
in the morning
drinking alone
to hide the frequency and the amount he
doesn't want you to know he drinks as
much as he does as often as he does
that's why he shows up with about 12
miniatures in his pocket oh weak bladder
willie he's the guy in the office who
goes to the to the bathroom about 82
times between arrival and lunch
and he comes back a little more woozy
after each trip
did you ever catch anybody at this is
why he gulps and sneaks he doesn't want
you to see him drink
did you ever walk into a kitchen at a
party you know and hear some clown in
there with a bottle and say hi there
hello
hey he's embarrassed he's caught at are
normal people embarrassed at taking a
drink of whiskey
no such thing he is
because he doesn't drink normally
he doesn't drink more that's not normal
drinking
change the pattern
i've got to do something about my
drinking so he switches from bourbon to
scotch to vodka to beer
let me show you what i meant in the
beginning
by lack of knowledge of this thing
there's one difference between a beer
alcoholic and whiskey alcoholic there's
the same amount of alcohol in 12 ounces
of beer as you'll find in an ounce of
whiskey simply means you gotta drink
more
and go the bathroom more often and it's
not worth it
especially on these cold winter nights
they tell one about a man who bought a
beer went in the men's room and just uh
flushed it down to john somebody said
you lost your mind he said no he's just
sick and tired of being the middle man
for him
any social behavior
let's put it this briefly and this
simply
have you ever said of someone you know
he's a wonderful fellow when he's sober
best worker when he's here
that's it now what do we mean by
anti-social
many parties are enhanced by inviting
some
specific person who gets half slopped up
and entertains everybody
not obnoxious at all he's simply funny
there's a difference between standing on
a piano and leading the songs
and busting into a neighbor's house on a
saturday afternoon after 19 rounds of
golf and hopping up on his piano with
your golf shoes on
and then puking on his rug this is gross
and this is frowned upon this is
anti-social and has repercussions
loss of friends
jobs
and families
i am not so much of a fool as to think
that these things can't happen as a
result of many other things but if they
result
from one's drinking then that's
alcoholism
and please i beg you if you remember
nothing else alcoholism is a family
disease and those who live with it get
as sick or sicker than the alcoholic
and they need treatment
let me show you what i mean and i don't
say this for shock value
a couple hours kids in our high schools
are going to be down the cafeteria
eating lunch
and at too many tables where they're
talking about some game they saw the
night before or some lesson they just
had in class there's going to be one kid
down the end with his face down in the
soup he's saying nothing guess what
happened in his house last night
at 2 30 in the morning he was shaking to
pieces listening to his dad
calling his mother a god damned [ __ ] in
the midst of a drunken rage
now this happens in your block
what happens in the heart of a little
eight-year-old girl who comes home from
school with a classmate and there's the
mother stark naked passed out in the
middle of dining room floor drunk
they don't get over these things they
can't ventilate them with anyone
most alcoholics recovered in a.a are
children of alcoholics and i don't think
because they inherited i think they
inherit attitudes caused by their
experience with an alcoholic
i have met women who have said to me
i've heard it so often father i'm
beginning to believe it myself i don't
know what i am
first of all they they they're
guilt-ridden because they blame
themselves for the husband's drinking
this is fantastic
alcoholism is indeed a result
of a combination of causative factors
it's not biochemical purely it's not
psychological or psychiatric purely it's
not emotional purely it's a combination
of all these things and they differ with
the individual
alcoholism in turn is productive
it's a symptom but it's not just a
symptom that's the half truth
because with this goofy word symptom in
mind we have focused on the causes and
not the problem two men
one a new york stock broker and the
other a physician surgeon from akron
ohio said let's treat the alcoholism
and they did and they found out what it
was causing cleared up when it cleared
up and now they were able with proper
therapy to face life without the
chemical
how many of you have discussed the drug
problem with a drink in your hand
the most overused drug on earth is
alcohol
it's alcohol
anyways
doctors and hospitals
you got cirrhosis drink again and you'll
die so he stays sober out of fear but
when he drinks again
after a protracted prolonged period of
sobriety he winds up on a bender or a
binge and he wonders what happened
remember what i said in the beginning
addiction is characterized by compulsive
use and once contracted it progresses
till death
when an alcoholic after 10 years of
sobriety drinks again he does not begin
at the beginning and he does not pick up
where he left off
he picks up where he would have been if
he had been drinking all that while why
is this nobody knows it's simply an
infallible fact
so the alcoholic can stay sober five
years and drink at the punch bowls bring
let the wise man think what they say in
japan first the man takes a drink then
the drink takes a drink then the drink
takes the man
he's over eight years and he says this
to himself i'm a man i can handle a beer
but all addiction goes from a lesser
amount to the greater amount from the
lesser drug to the greater drug he does
handle a beer and he may for a week
but sooner or later he's going to handle
two
and then five and he handles five shots
a few days later fifth and a half
handles him
tremors the inner shakes and screaming
for a drink
is indicative of a positive cellular
craving
for the drug without which he cannot
operate normally
this is an infallible sign of addiction
and ladies and gentlemen that is why
alcoholics drink
they don't drink because it rained or
didn't nor do they drink because of an
inferiority complex darn it that caused
the drinking but they drink today as a
result and symptom of their illness
in other words and briefly and those of
you who are writing can write it down
alcoholics drink because they are
alcoholics
the illness the nature of alcoholism to
use compulsively alcohol
in other words alcoholics drink because
they can't not drink
it's perfectly true that an alcoholics
freedom is missing and gone between
drinks 10 and 11. i maintain
that he's not free before the first
drink
the farther away the alcoholic is from
his last drink the closer he is to his
next one it is simply a question of time
and when it happens
we get down to here to try to explain it
the explanation is in the nature of his
addictive
nature
protect the supply
if you know anybody hides bottles you
know an alcoholic people don't hide milk
they don't hide orange remember days of
wine and roses this kid had one from
himself he hit it and then blacked out
unreasonable resentments
here's a wife been living for 15 years
for this and she she's totally
bewildered now if i say yes i'm wrong if
i say no i'm wrong see he's running out
of alibis and he needs a reason to drink
he's drinking compulsively tremendously
now
he doesn't know why and he's getting
flaky
so he comes home and he provokes her to
anger
and when she yells he drinks
he resents unreasonably
nameless fears and anxieties
the louder the mouth is scared of the
man alcoholism teaches one thing to its
victims how to be scared
till we come to the end of the line
the collapse of the alibi system
the tragedy for 35 out of 36
death occurs before it does
you know what that is it means the
alibis disappear i didn't get drunk last
night because the colts won or lost they
didn't play
i didn't get drunk because of her big
mouth she's gone
it's not the people i work with i don't
work and it's not the dog's birthday
he's dead
i drank because i couldn't help it i had
to drink he has looked into the mirror
of self and seen what is there he
reaches his moment of truth
the insanity of our reasoning is it true
to say you can't help an alcoholic until
he wants it yes
perfectly true
he will not respond to treatment
until he wants to
all i'm saying is get him into treatment
try to make him want to
that's all
you know what i'm saying in effect i'll
wait till he asks for help
god in heaven i'm looking at a man with
a sick mind
and asking him to make a major decision
about his life
i am presuming the very health of mind
that he needs and doesn't have
he can lead a horse to water and not
make him drink good gracious i know that
but you can lead him there and make him
thirsty
get him into treatment and see if he'll
respond okay but what might work
might work
let me ask you this how many of you have
ever walked down the street on a
beautiful spring day about a half hour
before lunch say gee i got a half hour i
think i'll go in that dentist off and
have a few teeth out
we don't function that way how can we
expect an alcoholic to say i think i'll
do something about my drinking problem
until he says i got one
and if he doesn't know he's got one it's
up to us to make him see it
i how about seeking treatment buddy or
seeking a new job you know like that
if he surrenders to his addiction
he winds up incarcerated
insane or dead
or he can surrender to help
there are clinics there is psychiatry
there is psychology and i beg you don't
undersell the virtue and the value and
the place of a return to one's religious
faith
as a component of complete recovery
but above all else what works best
for most is aa
face it ladies and gentlemen a thing on
god's good earth that works or succeeds
like success nothing
it is 12 principles by which to live
based on the first three i can't handle
it
god can
i believe i'll let him
it has worked to the tune of one half
million people
the programs that you will set up
in heaven's name
use the resources you have
available the professionals who know
what in god's name they are talking
about
tons of money are being dumped into drug
abuse and i think we know nothing about
drugs nothing
and we spin wheels and get a lot of
screw balls heading up these th forgive
me i don't mean to be stepping on
individual toes i'm just calling facts
use people who know something about
alcoholism to help in this
and i might leave with these few
thoughts number one to me an educated
man is one who has learned after a
number of years to say i don't know
i don't have all the answers we need
many people to do it there are
guidelines for industry
that have been found to be workable in
heaven's name find them out
secondly you have been more than kind
i appreciate more than you know you're
having me here to talk
i hope for those of you who can still
drink that i didn't spoil your drinking
for you
and if ever you meet somebody who
doesn't have a smile on his face give
him one of yours
thanks very kindly
you